hi and welcome to our cloud next session
on load balancers and today we're going
to be talking about the next generation
of our cloud load balancers
we've introduced many new features
recently and we're excited today to
share with you some of what those
features entail
but first let's talk
let me present to you our presenters so
adam michelson i'm a product manager at
google cloud and i help run the cloud
load balancers bobby do you want to
introduce yourself
hi everyone i'm bobby i'm also a product
manager on the load balancing team thank
you adam
awesome so with no further ado let's
dive right in
so today we're going to talk to you
about three items
one is next generation load balancing
we've been working to re-platform many
of our load balancers to include
advanced traffic control capabilities
our load balancers have been
re-platformed to run on top of the envoy
open source system and if you're
familiar with the envoy
system then many of these features may
be familiar to you and if you're not
that's totally fine you don't need to
know that platform to use our cloud load
balancers we'll also be talking about
how using this common platform will
enable you to have common capabilities
across our load balancers as well as
common control planes across our load
balancers
next we'll also be talking about
load balancing everywhere this is a
feature where you have services that run
off of google cloud such as on-prem or
in a multi-cloud environment how you can
connect to those services through our
load balancers so if you run services
that are not running on google you can
still access those services via our load
balancers
and finally we're going to talk to you
about some of our enterprise ready
features such as private service connect
which enables you to connect to third
party or services that are not
necessarily under your organization's
control
as well as how you can connect to
third-party applications so first we're
going to talk about some of our next
generation load balancing capabilities
so for the folks who may not be familiar
with our load balancers this is a quick
overview of our load balancers we have a
few load balancers in our load balancer
fleet
we have both a set of level seven https
load balancers as well as level four
network load balancers
most of the next generation capabilities
you're going to see in our level 7 load
balancers
so as we were saying
many of our load balancers are getting
an upgrade where we have advanced
traffic control capabilities brought by
envoy now envoy as i said earlier is an
open source platform if you're familiar
with the envoy platform then again these
services may be familiar to you
one of the commitments google has is to
the open source community and this is an
example of that where we work with the
envoy community to contribute
features back to that community and then
we consume those features into these
load balancers
so
as as part of that capability you'll see
our load balancer have consistent set of
features
also consistent with the open source
capabilities
and through that consistency you'll see
common control planes common
observability and common feature set
throughout our load balancers
during the initial release of our load
balancers that support envoy you'll have
so you'll see many new features
here on the right you'll see examples of
what those are
i'm not going to go through all of them
but i'll call out a couple so one
example is weighted traffic splitting a
weighted traffic splitting is used when
you roll out for example a new feature
or a new service and you want to test
that service such as running a canary
test across those services weighted
traffic splitting allows you to take a
certain percentage of your traffic one
two five fifty percent what have you and
push it to the new service you're
rolling out
another example is fault injection in
this example you can emulate what would
happen if you had a fault in your system
before it happens in production that way
you can harden your deployment to make
sure that when errors do
inevitably occur in production you've
had an opportunity to test them using
fault injection as an example
now this advanced traffic control
capability of our load balancer actually
extends beyond just load balancer
capabilities
for those who again may be familiar with
using something like an on voice side
car
this this example may be familiar to you
for those who are not
envoy again is an open source component
and platform which handles traffic
management
we have some of those capabilities built
natively into our load balancers and
again you don't have to understand envoy
at all
to use our load balancers they're just
native features of our load balancers
but for deployments that are
heterogeneous by nature multi-cloud or
on-premises
and you want a common feature set of
traffic control across cloud and
on-premises or multi-cloud
and you want common policy management
and control you can deploy what's called
an envoy sidecar which is a deployable
piece of code that can deploy next to
your services and those sidecar will
contain traffic control capabilities and
if you wish you can use a component such
as google's traffic director which is a
managed control plane that can push xds
configurations and controls into your
sidecars and it doesn't have to be envoy
it just has to be an xds compatible
service
so if you do that then
you can have some services sit behind
google cloud load balancers and other
services that have a side car sitting
next to them in google cloud or on
premises or in multi-cloud and in that
sort of architecture
you can handle a highly distributed set
of systems running across heterogeneous
systems but running as if they're
running in a homogeneous environment
because they're all standardized using
the envoy traffic control capabilities
they'll have
common features they'll have common
control planes they'll have common
observability
let's run through a quick example of how
this might be useful
so in this case imagine you're an
e-commerce provider and you have a
shared service across many components in
this case a wallet service that could be
maybe a payment processing engine now
here we have an e-commerce engine that
will use the external
global load balancer to access that
service
we also have a potentially a call center
using an internal load balancer which is
again hitting the same common
service and on the right side of this
picture you'll see the tension is point
of sale using regional load balancers or
maybe there's nightly batch jobs running
on premises maybe running front
protection so in all these cases you
have a common service that these various
systems are using so what happens if you
want to roll out a new service
a version two of the wallet each of
these disparate systems need to be able
to test that service using something
like a canary test that's pretty
complicated to do if each of these
systems has its own capabilities and
some may or may not have weighted
traffic splitting for example built in
but
if you're using something like an envoy
con
platform everywhere then you can use a
common weighted traffic
system across all these systems this
will be the same capability the same
control planes the same observability to
see if features are working or if
they're not working and in this way you
can go ahead and test
a secondary wallet service say version
two
and see if that service is working as
expected and once it is then you can
push all traffic to that new service and
so in this way if you do have a highly
distributed set or a complicated
architecture that has reusable services
whether it be just a distributed set of
services or a system like service mesh
you can use advanced traffic management
that's built natively into our load
balancers and other components
to reduce the toil and overhead of
managing a highly distributed set of
services so now what i want to do is run
you through a quick
demo to see this live in action
in this demonstration we're going to see
how to roll out a canary test here we
see four different services in the upper
left a global load balancer lower left
regional load balancer
upper right an internal load balancer
and in the lower right we see a sidecar
proxy here we're rolling out the various
commands required to be able to do our
canary test
now we're seeing that some traffic is
switching over from version one to
version two
in over the course of about 30 seconds
or so all the various
traffic management solutions load
balancer and sidecar proxies
are beginning to
send their traffic to both version one
and version two
the purpose is to make sure that version
two is handling traffic properly at this
point we see a lot of traffic going to
version two so now we're gonna say that
everything is working properly we're
going to send all of our traffic now to
the version 2 and away from version 1
and do our full rollout
so again we have the same four services
and we're going to run the commands
which are going to be common across
these various services to be able to
switch our traffic
onto the new updated version 2 wallet
service
and once again it takes about 30 seconds
or so for all the services to get their
command
and to switch all their traffic over to
version two and so now you see that all
the traffic at this point has been
switched to version two and our canary
rollout is complete
now that you've seen how the next
generation of load balancers can enable
advanced traffic management capabilities
across a highly distributed set of
services
i want to turn the conversation over to
bobby who is
going to run you through some of our
capabilities around load balancing
everywhere bobby
so one of the goals of our cloud load
balancing is to meet you where you're at
in your journey to cloud and as part of
that we have gone ahead and introduced
hybrid load balancing
so what is hybrid load balancing
you have clients that could be external
to google or internal
they send traffic to our external https
load balancing or external tcp proxy
or our internal https load balancing
these load balancers have back ends of
course on google cloud but now we have
enhanced them to also support back ends
on prem
and in other
clouds these on-prem and other cloud
back-ends
are connected to google
either by a public connectivity across
the internet
or by a private connectivity
through habpn or interconnects
what we're really excited to share with
you is that we have now in public
preview our hybrid load balancing with
support for on-prem and other cloud ends
via private connectivity
and we support health checking of these
backends
and we'd really like for you to try them
out
so how are some of our customers using
hybrid load balancing what are some of
the use cases
the most straightforward use case is
load balancing to workloads on-prem
more concretely you can imagine an erp
application
running on-prem
in a regional
extension
connected to google via partner
interconnects
the second use case is
protecting your on-prem workloads
against ddos attacks with cloud armor
or
you can use identity aware proxy
to authorize access to your on-prem
resources
you can enhance the latency experience
for your end users by caching static
content on cdn
the third use case
uses weighted traffic splitting that
adam had alluded to earlier
to do a gradual migration of workloads
from on-prem to google
now we are working on additional use
cases such as
supporting
failover from on-prem to google
as we develop more and more we shall
share them with you
now
let us turn our attention to how we are
enhancing our enterprise users with
hybrid load balancing use cases
so what we are focused on is reducing
the operational tile
and
meeting the scale and security
requirements for our enterprise users
in this regard first let us look at
private service connect
so what is private service connect
you know in typical customer deployments
you have multiple teams
producing services for consumption by
other teams
the groups offering these services could
be part of the same organization
or they could be third-party services
or services offered by google
the way you typically set this up
securely is via private connectivity
by setting up peering between the
producer and the consumer
but you run into a lot of operational
toil and scale constraints with peering
now this is where private service
connect comes in
it is our converged service connectivity
offering
because it does this through private
connectivity it is secure
you don't have the scale constraints
that you have with peering and it can
scale to thousands of endpoints
it is also very performant you get line
rate because there is no proxy in the
middle
now how does this private service
connect actually work
well you have a producer and a consumer
in the producer you set up the service
behind a load balancer
and a service attachment point
in the producer's address space
this service attachment point
is linked to endpoints in the consumer's
address space
the workloads in the consumer wishing to
access end points
simply send traffic to the end points in
their own address space
so how does load balancing
work with private service connect
let's start with the producer
the internal https load balancer and the
internal layer 4 load balancer helps you
scale out your service and makes it
highly available
now remember how i was referring to
hybrid load balancing the internal https
load balancer now supports endpoints
on-prem
so you can use the private service
connect to offer a service
residing on-prem securely without having
to worry about overlapping ip address
space
on the consumer front
we are now working on
putting these
psc endpoints behind our http load
balancers external or internal
with the url maps that are associated
with this http load balances
you get fine grained control and
selection of which
producer services that you route to
you also can now log every service
invocation with our https load balancing
login
in addition for external services that
access the hps load dancer you can put a
cloud armor and protect against ddos
attacks
or use our managed tls offering to
secure the service further
now i'm excited to share with you
another capability that we have enhanced
for our enterprise users and that is
integration with third-party appliances
so a lot of our enterprise users as they
migrate to google cloud wish to bring
their favorite third-party appliances
with them as part of their lift and
shift
with our ilps next hop
we have made it
very seamless and scalable integration
of these appliances by a bump in the
wire mechanisms
what we've done is gone ahead and
enhanced that
with three additional enhancements
the first one is support for symmetric
hashing
you know when you have these multiple
stateful firewall appliances and you
have bi-directional traffic you need to
ensure that the return traffic hits the
same instance on the way back
you typically do this by configuring
source line but there's a lot of
operational toil associated with it
but now by using symmetric hashing with
our layer 4 internal load balancer for
bi-directional flows you no longer have
that constraint and toil
the second enhancement that we've done
is we've enabled all protocols to flow
through ilb as next job not just tcp and
udp
so now by allowing icmp packets through
we'll be able to support ping and trace
routes so that you can better
troubleshoot your flows
last but not the least we've also added
tagging support for your load balancers
what this effectively does is it allows
you to group a certain set of endpoints
with a tag and associate them with an
ilp
and route your traffic from those
clients specifically to that ilp
the most common use case has been
regionalization where you can tag all
workloads in a specific region and
associate them with that ilb
in that specific region
we have a very compelling roadmap of our
load balancing offerings and features
let me share some of them with you
if you look at this roadmap across the
board we have multiple flavors and
features of our load balancing
what i'd like to bring your attention to
is in the security column
you'll see that we've made tls 1.3 the
default for our https load balancers
with perfect forward secrecy getting rid
of old less secure ciphers we made our
solution more secure
by cutting down on the handshakes
and the setup latency we've resulted in
a much more optimal end user experience
on the scaling front if you'll notice
we've added support for layer 4 ilb
subsetting what this allows you to do is
to scale your back ends more than 255 of
your layer folder balancer and hence
scale out your service
much more
now let me hand it off to adam to wrap
this session up
thank you thanks so much bobby so i
wanted to thank all of you first who
joined us today and i hope you enjoyed
our session and found it informative
and also wanted to
present to you other networking sessions
that are happening if you're interested
in other topics and of course with our
load balancers we'd love it if you would
have the opportunity to try them out and
we always are interested to hear your
feedback in terms of which features are
working for you and what enhancements
you would like to see so with that i'd
like to thank you and nice for my my
behalf and bobby's as well and we do
hope that you enjoy the rest of your
next sessions
you